لكن هل هل الاوراق عسكريه فقط يعني جربنا
في عام 73 ورقه النفط مثلا هل هل هنالك
تعقيدات الان تمنع استخدام ما لدى الدول
العربيه من اوراق قوه اولا لحمايه نفسها
من حرب شامله وثانيا لوقف مذبحه واباده
جماعيه تجري في غزه على الاقل وفق قضيه
جنوب افريقيا التي قدمت لمحكمه العدل
الدوليه هل الاوراق فقط يجب ان تكون
عسكريه اليست هنالك اوراق اخرى بيد الدول
العربيه سيد زونز
[موسيقى]
بالتاكيد هنالك طلق اخرى لتسليط الضغط
بالاضافه الى الاساليب
او الاجراءات العسكريه لان الاجراءات
العسكريه قد تؤدي الى ردود عسكريه كما نرى
الان بين الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
بالتالي الاجراءات الاقتصاديه
والدبلوماسيه قد تكون اكثر فعاليه وقد
تكون مخاطرها اقل لكن ليس من الواضح
لماذا بعض الدول العربيه لم تكن نافذه
اكثر في مساله او مصممه اكثر في مساله
مواجهه الولايات المتحده في دعمها
لاسرائيل لكن
مصداقيتها الان
مهدد بسبب فشلها في القيام بذلك لان
شعوب شعوب المنطقه شعوب الشرق الاوسط
يشعرون بالترويع والرعب من القتل المستمر
لاخوانهم الفلسطينين يشعرون باحباط كبير
عندما يرون حكوماتهم غير قادره او غير
راغبه باتخاذ اجراءات اكثر قوه نيابه عن
الشعب
الفلسطيني وبالتالي ما هي الاجراءات
الاكثر قوه في وجهه نظرك ما الذي يمكن ان
يفعله العرب اكثر من ذلك اكثر من التعبير
عن رفضهم
وامتعاضه ونصحهم للولايات المتحده ما الذي
بيدهم فعليا ليفعلوه
من الغريب لي كا امريكي ان اقدم النصح
للدول العربيه ربما حول هذا الامر بالاخذ
من الاعتبار ان حكومتي هي التي ربما
مسؤوله بشكل اساسي عما تقوم به اسرائيل
اعتقد ان العبء الحقيقي يقع على كاهل
الشعب الامريكي بكي يكون اكثر صرامه في
تغيير سياسات حكومته في نفس الوقت
وبسبب ان الولايات
المتحده تجد من المهم جدا ان تتمتع
بعلاقات جيده مع الدول العربيه فان
الاجراءات قد تبدا من سحب السفراء الى فرض
عقوبات متعلقه بالنفط ربما او الرفض
رفض اي تحركات اضافيه
ومد علاقات دبلوماسيه مع اسرائيل او تطبيع
العلاقات مع
اسرائيل وايضا
توضيح مساله
ربما ان العقود التجاريه او العلاقات قد
ته تتهدد اذا ما استمرت هذه الاجراءات
والسياسات من قبل الولايات المتحده لكن
كما قلت المسؤوليه الاساسيه تقع نحن على
كاهلنا نحن الشعب الامريكي في من اجل
تغيير السياسات الحكوميه هناك